and
again now you're you're dipping you're
not rolling it's cuz you're you're over
yourself too much
go back that's it see for comfortable
roll the stomach so in other words
that's it
yes that's better
yeah see I'm
already
yeah pretty good
yes
very yeah it's nice to um you mean
you're feeling this it's nice to receive
as well because you it's less of an
obvious release you have you see it
going like around there you can get out
so you actually have to like yeah I can
so let's let's have a look where we've
used the J to find out how we
understanding so now we
have done
here we come here he
lifts you do the
for I forgot you lifted oh yeah here we
go there we come
here we we release
him we come
here so now we've got
taret you need you need to push yourself
to the Remy even though it's not
necessarily and the reason why I'm say
Remy is because I'm going to show you
the f i
Comey you come here this is natural
color G you see how that adjustment was
made by him not me even though I was
doing it was made by him I release
it if I do this this and I now come in
I'm going to be as
you I'm
actually in a dangerous
place and what happens is you know
sometimes you'll get this where you
change feet on the spot and you think
don't know why I done that I actually
haven't gained any
distance so do that and that is the
problem so when you're here and you come
up and he lifts cuz you do it quick you
get pushed down you know so if he was to
cut again
then yeah and then you said off felt
like that over there you get that but if
you go for the AR you have to go you
know how we go straight here we're
entering we go pretty much
stra and the reason there is because of
this the Remy is